my finding is only half of women turning
30 without a child ever become a mother
and that's Global screening the final
film to to younger people have screened
it to 12 14 17 year olds through college
age people the fire in the eyes of those
young people who I think I would
describe often feel anger at realizing
that we us the adults haven't actually
thought this through you know we're
telling them do your homework study get
that education training get on the
career path all of this and I think
young people mostly are assuming that
we've thought this through that that
must mean that in their 30s more likely
than not there are going to be able to
have the family that they want to have
when they see people grieving reality
that that didn't happen